so welcome everybody now I'd like you to
relax and get comfortable because we're
gonna be up here for about half an hour
talking and then I'll open it up to you
guys and invite you to jump into the
conversation and Megan I've had the
opportunity to interview many times even
interview you many times over the years
and I want to make sure that we spend a
lot of time talking about the big
priorities for our nation and what
you're doing in DC but I'd love to start
in a more intimate place Megan I want to
know when you decided you liked science
I think that's a question um I'm gonna
go to Buffalo on Friday which is where
I'm from and talk at my high school
which would be really it's really nice
to go back she's going Friday because it
will have stopped snowing by then I love
come on I go anytime
actually just a tech thing you know kids
we moved to DC and every day this fall
Louie would say Siri when is it going to
snow so that's the modern version of
excitement for snow so I think my family
is incredibly entrepreneurial and
progressive and so my parents were
always doing all these things so I don't
think it was that science and specific
but it was like impact so whether it was
going to this place called TIF farm
where we just went for the weekend it
was like the city dump which is now a
super cool park and just pulling tires
and stuff out and being environmentalist
basically my dad started the recycling
center for Buffalo they they work
together to start the bike routes you
know and this was in the 70s before it
was there too you know the same thing as
critical mass was existing in those
movements and they were part of that my
dad was doing a lot of art at the time
he was actually he did business but he
also did a lot of art stained glass and
other other pieces like that and brought
us in on that I remember like we would
make our teachers projects you know for
Christmas so we would make stained glass
so we just had a real hands-on
experience my mom was a kindergarten and
a preschool teacher so I
think it wasn't that anything in
specific a science really maybe more
making and engineering building things
what was your school like that was a
really extraordinary so during all the
busing that was going on in the 70s the
you know people were lying down in front
of buses it was so crazy and Buffalo did
this really creative thing where they
did all these magnet schools later
Clinton came and copied Buffalo for the
Little Rock school so it's really a
fabulous school system and so our school
started as we were kids and so we got to
watch our teachers make our school so
that was like middle school elementary
school we have middle sort of seventh
grade through twelfth grade and so
getting to see these entrepreneurial
teachers do their thing with basically
no money you know because these are
interested passionate about what they
were doing and what was the what was the
result of the experiment I mean you're
going on Friday so I assume the school
still exists it's an amazing school
actually was the number four school in
the Newsweek poll I think two or three
years ago in the country still
inner-city you know the school public
school just extraordinary at the time
was more scrappy and now it's a little
more organized and they've had you know
Intel science winners and and those
things but one of the things that they
did that made a huge difference in my
life in in being coming technical was it
science fair was mandatory and so
everybody did science fair it was part
of class all the way through high school
and also mr. Safin and mr. Keene who
were our math teachers who were awesome
they had the draft for math club math
team so most math teams are just the
kids who figured out it's fun to do and
they're doing it and everyone else
doesn't know or thinks it thinks it's
nerdy years and so they made us do it
and so he had asked like every kid did
it or like you got a number they
basically made pretty much every kid do
it or at least the kids who were kind of
good performers or whatever and they
just made us all do it you know the kids
who would have been in the in the play
but they were in the math team and they
were in the play so it was there every
moment when you were bitter about that
as a kid no I liked it and it it just
exposed us the things they just exposed
us to the breadth of everything actually
one other thing they did that was
extraordinary was one of our teachers
wrote over
for a grant when I was I think a
sophomore and instead of starting school
and I wish all schools did this they
started on whatever right after Labor
Day and the for the first those first
three days plus the week
all the teachers changed gears and they
just did some teaching thing and you
could join whatever you want and I I
joined our physics teachers seminar
basically which was called the city as
an ecosystem and they took us in that
particular one some people were doing
architecture or art or anything that was
city based and they had won this grant
to do it to pay for it and so we went to
the sewage treatment plant and the water
treatment plant and all the ecosystem of
our city and learns our the mechanics of
how it physically worked and was amazing
we went on our bikes because we didn't
have any money we'd like find bikes or
borrow bikes and and so these teachers
were just astonishing and they just got
it done and they treated us really well
believed in us and got us working
together as a team we came from all
across the city and so what was college
like for you um it was was it a
no-brainer that you were gonna study
engineering or did you consider doing
other things I was like I was the kid
who did solar and wind things all the
time in Buffalo of course you know if
Solar is so big and what but I was I was
inspired it was actually came full
circle for me and the White House
because the president was going up on
the roof and President Obama to see the
solar panels on the Department of Energy
and I had been inspired from President
Carter putting the solar panels on the
White House so it's like this is an
interesting day and so just we ever in
an energy crisis and so I was coming to
understand how you use technology and
science to make a difference to solve a
problem that's really significant on
behalf of the nation with something I
got to do early on and so I something
can't I think came to our school about
an NSF course out in Colorado so I ended
up doing a small summer class called
solar energy and energy engineering at
the University of Colorado Boulder and
it was in the civil engineering
department I'm like oh what we're doing
is this engineering thing so that's how
I found out what it was
in addition despite my family being a
bunch of nurse from my grandfather and
so from that I apply I just looked for
mechanical engineering I would worked in
a bike shop so I wanted more things that
of engineering versus things that are
still and I just looked at the list and
I applied to some of the schools and MIT
was on the top so I applied to it didn't
really understand what it was and so I
went to visit and I ended up getting in
and I was the first kid for my school to
get in and so my biology teachers like
you're going there ever ever yeah well
we were new and so I remember getting my
emissions and and I had to wait for
financial aid cuz I was an inner-city
kid and so I remember like opening it up
and doing the math and I could do this
in this and figure and I could make it
happen I can make it work now you were
in the very early days at MIT Media Lab
- right so what was that like it was
incredible so I I did mechanical
engineering and worked for the guy named
woody flowers who I just was at the
FIRST Robotics nationals all that first
robotic stuff was stuff he worked on but
at the university level so that was part
of more the design core in mechanical
engineering and then the Media Lab
started when I got to grad school and
what's great and in stem is they pay for
grad school so for those were interested
and it's a good thing so you know
there's these research assistantship and
somebody told me about the Media Lab and
so I went over and I ended up working
with alan kay who had been the lead for
Xerox PARC and marvin minsky founder of
AI and this amazing apple project which
in my particular project is mechanical
engineer was making it how you you could
feel what you see on the screen sort of
haptics which still hasn't really come
yet but it will come it's here a little
bit uh-huh so so how many years ago is
that you don't have to say it was when
it was right when we did the solar car
race across Australia at the same time
which was 1987 and we're just writing
about haptics again as about to finally
have some sort of impact yeah so we saw
in the video the the early smartphone
would you call it an early smartphone
yeah I reckon so tell us a little bit
about general magic general magic was a
company that was founded actually within
Apple a guy named Mark Pratt had an idea
he called it paradigm and it was it was
basically this but you saw in the video
it was like this big and it really was
exactly a smartphone
it was the
of a person it was cute they call their
personal the intelligent communicator
and the idea of it was a device that you
took around that had apps and could do
communication and content and e-commerce
and he had the cloud and he had all
these devices connected and they had all
these services it was exactly the
Internet he had the cloud like a picture
of a clip it was like a cloud this is
1990 get a cloud and then he had you
know smart phones and TVs and the phone
on your desk all this stuff connected
and then he had these different services
that were content communications
commerce and I forget the last one but
they're all the stuff that's happening
so what you think Megan back in 1990
what did you think that people were
gonna use it for exactly what they use
it for it we really were onto that and
you know it was a time I would
mechanical gender so I was doing an
engineering like there were no things
like this so we had to figure out touch
screens and what screen size and
wouldn't that video that you saw was us
figuring out what kind of touch screen
we were gonna use and what size for this
stuff be sort of reminds me of the
beginning of internet advertising and
figure out the sizes of IAB ads you know
we all of the devices should have
buttons and how should it work and then
Susan care who did all the graphics on
the original Mac it was much of the Mac
team Andy Hertzfeld and Bill Atkinson
Joanna Hoffman all these amazing people
from the Mac team had come to do this
and so we worked on this and in fact
Pierre Omidyar who founded eBay was
there and he was in the developer
relations team working with all these
third-party developers who were making
apps for the phone it was just too early
no one knew what we were talking about
so no one had email yet so we knew
there's coming it was too big still also
it was like so what happened to general
magic um it you know like many things in
soca valley it became the next things so
so Android Andy Rubin was there he is
Andy droid Android and now he works on
robots and other things and he he was
there and he went on to do danger and
then eventually create Android and go
forward Tony Fadell came from school
Tony created the iPod with Steve Jobs
so the iPod heritage which is the iPhone
came out of there you know
eBay and the early device and outside of
it so many people
we're in that company who then spun out
I do so it was not destined to happen in
that company but it's really the
heritage like some people in the chips
world know a company called Fairchild
that later Intel really is the one that
gets it done and so it's sort of the
Fairchild of smartphones so as you're as
you're naming these people they're
essentially the lions of Silicon Valley
today Megan and as you think back on
this the arc of your career which
mirrors the arc of the growth of the
internet um what would you point to as
perhaps the turning moment in your
career you know I think it just builds
on itself in a lot of ways you just it's
a you it's a combination of having the
energy like like to go forward but also
amazing luck that comes and astonishing
people that you meet who are doing great
things and having having the courage and
the initiative and the go for it with
them hey that's a crazy idea that just
might work right you know and joining
them in that where any of those
decisions hard though because I mean
looking at them from from this
perspective it looks like you made a lot
of great decisions but when you're on
the other side of it you don't know if
they're gonna be great yet I mean Google
is that a thing should you go there yeah
I think it's a today I just I believe in
people and so and the ideas and so you
sort of bet on your teammates together
and you see what you can do I was I went
right out of school actually went to
Tokyo were for Apple and that's where I
met you know Bill Atkinson and some of
these other folks and Bill was spinning
out with Mark Braud to make this general
magic company spinning out of the Apple
at the time and Motorola and Sony and
all the folks were investing and I had a
chance I had interviewed I was going to
stay in Japan and go into a Japanese
company to just learn more actually
interviewed my Japanese is so bad now
but the especially at the prime minister
ah becoming the but I had interviewed in
Japanese that got the job at Nissan I
can't believe I did those long time ago
forgotten all of it um you want to try
it out on us No
actually there was a line in media lab
that there were many Japanese fellows
and this the first thing I learned in
Japanese watashi no huarache have a much
the cuff which is having eaten my
toothbrush
you know it's Kenji had a say to all the
Japanese visitors all the time and they
would look at us like what are you
talking about um we were down by two
students but anyway so the way I had I
don't know I think I think it was sort
of coming I came back you know into into
choosing to do a startup was what I
decided to do instead of go in the
Japanese company and I think at that
time I wrote down all the things I
wanted to learn and when people come and
ask me for advice about what they want
to do I often suggest that it was really
helpful to me I wrote down all the
things I wanted to learn and I would
learn in this choice or in this choice
and then just thought about it and I
wanted to learn more about how to ship a
product and so I decided to come to
Silicon Valley which is a great place to
learn how to ship a product it turns out
yeah yeah but a lot of stuff is
serendipity like when I left general
magic it was too early so it sort of
curved up and it didn't make it and my
friend Tom Riley had founded Planet out
and he needed help and so sometimes I'm
not often the founder but I'm there
early there's these Reed Huffman calls
us the smart generalists that you need
if you're a founder you need them in
your team and so you know I think it's
very important especially for our young
people how do we help people jump into
startups and even if they don't we
obsessed sometimes on the founder but
it's really those founding teams that
are so exciting and so fun so I helped
get planted out over the finish line for
a couple of its early launches as a
contractor and then we had a bunch of
issues with choosing the wrong CEO that
Tom had and so things flipped around we
had to buy back the company from the VCS
and so I ended up running the company
and it was an amazing thing to get to do
is an honor and you went right from
planted out to Google right pretty much
Louie was born so I spent our older son
and so and Cara was writing a book so I
spent a bunch of time with him during
his first year and then I went to Google
okay so tell us a little bit about I was
trying to decide between founding Lee
and working at Google and I think we'll
go with Google and this
Bakula so tell us a little bit about
your work at Google and there's some
colleagues here you know Tim Armstrong
was there of course
nowaday well amazing time with him and
others who are here the Google's it was
incredible I remember
it's definitely fly the plane and build
the plane at the same time I joined when
we are about 1200 people and we're not
maternally for Alex our other son and
the company doubled in size home and I
was only gone like three and a half
months so it was impressive and just
amazing and incredibly talented
passionate mission driven people to work
with I got to David Drummond was running
a team there was early stage business
development and so we were helping the
engineering and product management teams
start things so whatever deal work they
needed to do whether it was tech
licensing or first-of-a-kind deal so we
got to basically the team that was quite
small we also did that positions like
Earth and maps and those others but I
got to be that we got to be the team and
Kristin Moore ceadeus here from that
team we got to help the engineers do
basically everything that Google started
so it was in a stunning thing so you
just had to stay with them and help them
keep moving forward it sounds sort of
similar to the job that you have now in
many ways yes because I was flashing on
that Alex mcgillvary was there who's now
deputy CTO was general counsel at
Twitter for many years after Google he
and I worked on book search in the
beginning so figuring out how to work
with the publishers and what would the
deal be in how would that be structured
and he was on the legal side and I was
on the deal side and new business
development is a lot of what you did at
Google but you wore a lot of hats at
Google right you were involved with
google.org you were involved with Google
X well what did you do with Google X the
Google X I was part of the leadership
team and so working a lot Sergey was
running ax and Astro with him the thing
that I ended up doing there was not only
working with particular teams but really
starting a couple like company-wide
initiatives one of them was a little
more Google X called solve for X and
Pune two heroes here who does that what
did that work of me which is really many
of the solutions that we need in the
world are here we just have to find that
person and get them distributed get them
more nagy get them more resources so X
being sort of a variable for passion so
we would find people in every continent
doing a maze
work on energy breakthroughs or food and
nutrition breakthroughs or water
breakthroughs and try to give them a
ted-like stage where they would propose
their idea and so we do like kind of
four proposals in a row and then have an
amazing curated room of people we could
gather from lots of different cross
functional areas engineers policy makers
others and have them help two thirds yes
and and one third yes but brainstorming
and then report out and it was really
helpful to the entrepreneurs and it got
their voice out there on ideas that we
really needed to solve so we did that
work and we also started something
called I started something with some
colleagues called women techmakers which
is very much about it's based on the
idea that there's 16 million programmers
in the world roughly and that means
there's two to three million women why
don't you ever see them and so women
techmakers like makers the visibility is
so important and so if you can't be what
you can't see which is what Geena Davis
I says about the lack of girls and
technical girls and technical people of
minority and children's television same
thing at all of our conferences so I
love what you guys are doing here
because technical women are amongst the
most invisible because they're invisible
in technology and they're also invisible
amongst women typically women are tend
to not be doing tech stuffs that they
doing something between makers and wired
is a brilliant idea just because the
role models are here they've always been
here we just need to see them and so
that was what women techmakers was about
well that's really what we're hoping to
do with the event Megan so
congratulations on your new role of CTO
we love having you in the East Coast
you are among family and friends and you
called this role you have when we
interviewed for for the wired story and
I have to read it because it's specific
and architecture and instigation job
yeah you know I think that way because
it's not like you're running government
engineering like you're not you're the
chief technology officers often in
companies also it's an architecture job
you're not running NASA or the National
Institute of Health
you're not running government IT your
help
to bring technology innovation and data
practice to everything you can convince
and get going that and trying to
prioritize amongst that so we do a lot
of work on tech policy so the net
neutrality work or broadband or privacy
big data discrimination and big data
looking out for that patent reform all
of those topics of the day
so whatever the hot topics are the CTO
team is at the table as technical people
I caught TQ so it's to take your net
neutrality yeah you're at the table like
what table who's there Obama's dinner
table what's he eat No so actually it's
interesting it was so interesting to
learn how the policy process works
because I hadn't been exposed to that
and so the way that this is done it
reminds me of maybe it's incredibly
collaborative and it draws from the best
of people's knowledge whether their
documents get circulated people can
comment from all across government
you're reaching out across all the
different constituency I mean the FCC
ran that process where they got four
million comments and then so they did
all kinds of analysis on that and what
people thought what they wanted you're
trying to capture the voice of anybody
who wants to say something on that topic
make sure you've heard it so it's an
incredibly inclusive process what I
think is slightly different now is at
the main table you go through a general
drawing you you pull a lot of
information then there's a deputies
counselor deputy committee meeting and
then there's principals and so the
deputies debate and organize all this
stuff and then the principal's meet
you're making decisions and what has not
been happening at the principal's table
on technical topics in the past is there
weren't always engineers at the table
and so you have extraordinarily talented
Americans economists legislative folks
legal folks etc and now we've added that
extra set of seats of technical people
both the Office of Science Technology
Policy where was we're embedded and also
the CTO team that makes a big difference
in the room I mean it's a head scratcher
that you wouldn't have engineers as part
of these big technical decisions you
have them but they're consulted got it
or they're thought of as implementation
they haven't in the architecture of the
conversation and that's changed and
we do it as a country when we're at war
we bring everyone together as fast as we
can and we start solving things I mean
we invented computers the UK if you saw
an imitation game they you saw the
Bletchley Park team we had the ENIAC and
other teams here that just did
breakthrough work as class collaborative
but what as when we're in peacetime we
kind of get separated out and so one of
the great things that President Obama is
doing is I think post healthcare.gov
that was an experience where he learned
that there were a set of people missing
from government and he went to go get us
and he's bringing a lot of people in and
we CTO team Jen pahlka who did Code for
America and Todd Park who was CTO before
me their teams together with colleagues
across Office of Management and Budget
and other agencies architected what is
now the u.s. digital service and so in
addition to the policy table is talking
about there's also the implementation of
tech and government and the beginning of
what I call digital government so I
think we should just unpack this a
little bit because even when we did our
interviews there were there were so many
different sort of areas to keep track of
and it seems like your job is a lot
about collaborating and helping those
people work together right and so when
you're talking about the Todd Parkes
group they're in there not okay look
you've already lost me okay you're over
there in the West Coast and they work
under a different organization than you
work under right but you still help
recruit for them and work very closely
with them right yeah so think of us as
like an architect or like in a tech
company maybe of like board member right
so we're we're trying to I P oh the
best-in-class
tech through whoever wants to do that
with us so whether it's the VA or
whether it's the Department of
Agriculture or whoever that is they need
to be the best in class and so what's
been missing is we're a country that
makes Amazon we make Facebook we make
AOL we make these things and those
Americans have not been in government at
elite levels or they have been but
they're buried underneath and only
called on to make stuff like let us
design a website without any
when tactical and here please build this
and we all know as tech people that it
had the best stuff gets built when the
marketing people and the writing people
and the coding people and the art people
are all working together and also making
like first versions and prototypes not
making a spec that's gonna be built
across five years I can you imagine
Amazon writing a spec for what they're
gonna build across five years they would
never do that now and so we need to not
do that anymore and so you still are
having we're gonna have great people
outside of government building this
stuff so you'll be contracting but you
can contract better so Megan you are the
third u.s. CTO that we have had and with
Obama in office for another 18 19 months
you have at least ninety four weeks or
so first you have you have what two
people outside of tech might seem a
limited time of course you point out
that if you work in tech I mean nineteen
months you could be IP owing a company
in that what do you hope to do what are
your priorities yeah so we work in these
three areas the policy area this digital
government area and then an area I call
innovation nation which is work that
we're doing to help the American people
get in on this innovation economy that
we're all part of in addition to all of
us here sort of in the New York tech
scene how do we also get folks from all
different regions in on this like tech
hire which is a project that Jeff
science in the National Economic Council
and I put together with president around
jobs so we have five million jobs open
in in the country half a million of Amer
in tech and we don't have enough
four-year degree folks to fill those
jobs so we have to think more creatively
so take those people and what else and
the companies are starving for talent
from net an economy perspective we want
people to have those jobs we need the
companies we need the companies to stay
here we were finding things like the San
Antonio folks were spending fifteen
thousand dollars bringing people you
know from other parts of the country
other parts of the world they're like
why are we doing this so they founded a
coding bootcamp for Rackspace to do
cloud-based tech and now they have all
kinds of people in San Antonio who would
have never been intact joining in months
not years so that half a million jobs I
mean where in the country are they
they're not
for the most part in Silicon Valley well
that's right and so there I was just in
st. Louis last week and the launch code
team is there who is the st. Louis
incubator Louisville is doing this work
Philly's doing this work everywhere in
the country this is happening people are
using these short course boot camps
three months of training some
apprenticeship sometimes they're
independent but they're slowly getting
into community colleges they're coming
onto the base so the veterans can do it
and then people can get into these
companies but the companies have to do
is adapt their hiring practices to
include ways to evaluate this person who
has a different kind of resume but still
pull them in and that's happening and
there's cohorts of companies helping
each other do it and then there's me
municipal leaders like here in New York
Penny's here from the New York team they
are also facilitating and helping moving
workforce dollars maybe we're for us
programs that get the word out and then
the Department of Labor put up a hundred
million dollar grant that already exists
for this funding but adapting it to let
people apply for any kind of innovative
they had ideas that they have in these
kinds of boot camp on-road onboarding
programs that we can do across the
country so in doing that it seems to me
that you'll you'll also get a more
diverse group of workers as well yeah
and that's in fact that's the whole
focus we just had a tech meetup the
first ever tech meetup at the White
House so we took 50 with Scott and the
meetup team 50 of the top meetup
organizers in the country and then we
put them together with folks who are
doing amazing work on these boot camps
some of my favorite ones are like
digital nest Watsonville California
where lots of our strawberries come from
they've created a Silicon Valley like
space and they've got the migrant worker
youth they pay them in they're doing
tech stuff and so they're onboarding all
kinds of people who are near Sikkim
Valley into that world so you have lots
of that kind of unusual training all
around to bring people in so um before
we finish up tonight I want to make time
for a couple of questions do we have
anybody from the audience with something
to ask okay yes
of all you got out fourth-grade hey I've
got one Jessie way back in that bag that
know what it what's your name sir I bet
of all the things that you've done which
are extraordinary is this the most
daunting do you think you can really
move this needle this is the most
exciting it's it's incredibly welcoming
and the president and his team Denis
McDonough who's the chief of staff
everywhere returned people are hungry to
try to figure this out and people are
incredibly entrepreneurial and they're
extraordinarily talented and they
haven't had us the techies show up for
them with them and we need to show up
and so we're trying to structure you the
u.s. digital service so the people can
come for Sprint's and just come and
debug something we just had an amazing
marketing team come for two years we
just said David korten came for a short
time to work on IT from Facebook and he
just decided to stay so we were very
happy people come for two months they
can come for a year they can come for a
pairs of time and we're working with the
tech companies to let people take leaves
to come it's I think that we need to
think that way like our government will
only be what it is based on all of us as
talented people showing up and helping
and being part of it and I hope that
Alex McGilvery and I were talking about
when we went we were thinking like how
would we change the brand of government
and would we ever be able to talk to
somebody let's say you're talking to at
you know a 30 year old techie and they
say to you I'm gonna join you know fill
in the blank I've got an offer from you
know Dropbox Twitter whatever a really
cool company I might do this startup and
I've got some pretty good backing ideas
and that or am i doing the VA digital
service and that that would be a totally
credible thing to say and the good news
is that we just got the number three
employee of Amazon to join the VA her
coat is everything you see you know with
the smile box is going around for all
these years and what is your second act
after you know you do Amazon it's the
American veterans and helping them I
mean serving them as an extraordinary
thing to be able to do and so everywhere
look the scale of government is
incredible and
thing that government can do is serve
our poorest Americans and help them and
we know how to do amazing things that we
can help our teammates who have these
awesome policies or business models they
know their thing and when we get
together we really solve a lot of
problems quickly and then on the higher
side like the innovative side I always
say Henry Ford didn't have anything
against horses he just had a new idea
and so how do we help the regulator's
see through the idea of like sandboxing
in test cases and how do we help keep
the America's America's top innovators
moving and get out of their way well we
still protect the American people
protect privacy do the things that we
need to do as government so it's those
things together that were really focused
on like unlocking talent you know I was
lucky to be a Ferguson and in the high
school because we went to first robotics
Nationals and on Friday and so we went
to grab their robot team to come to and
just those kids need to be in on this
game too and their parents and how are
we doing that as a country with 500 tech
meetups a day those Americans are
everywhere just need the other people in
their cities to meet them and just start
innovating the way we all do and
collaborating and so I want to throw our
last question out to Tim back there I
wanted to quickly start playing a quick
infomercial for Megan I think Megan is
one of the most exceptional people in
this country and an exceptional leader
an exceptional person I think we're
exceptionally lucky to have you in the
government Megan so thank you for doing
it and my question is you know there's
been a lot of discussion tonight and and
what you do about the US but I'm
wondering if you have counterparts in
other countries and how many countries
have a CTO at this point and what do you
think the United States opportunity is
to lead on a global scale also in this
this environment yeah we this is a
really exciting thing that Corey's
Erica's in my team who runs all the open
government work live for us just came
back from Mexico City where the Open
Government Partnership folks are meeting
president has started the open
government partnership with seven other
countries he's unlocked 120,000 data
sets since being in office by just doing
like to the structure really clever rule
making around how you get the agencies
and the way that the executive branch it
moves we have animal analytics at
usa.gov now so you can see our
Linux we started doing that because of
the UK the UK has the government digital
service you can see there they're super
digital and they actually started this
thing called the d5 which is digital
like GG 8d whatever and fill in the
blank number and the first five are the
UK estonia israel north let's say South
Korea and New Zealand and those folks
all have open-source policies they're
communicating putting a lot of stuff
online they're teaching coding or on
track to teach coding to every child in
their country and so we're hoping to
join that Mexico is working on joining I
think Australia so I think we're we're
in sort of the Jeff science who's the
director of the National Economic
Council hustla often has this idea of
like imagine a marathon where's like
those frontrunners and then there's the
front of the pack and everybody after
we're definitely in that front runner
group there's some other great countries
there with us and it's fun to work with
the national security council because as
we get them and when they're doing very
formal visits we're like okay let's have
a multi lat
and it looks like an email thread so you
know we're just talking to the CTO of
the UK or talking to the CTO of India
who's moving really fast
Brazil is moving really fast that's it's
great to see you know this happening all
over the world and then putting a hero
who's here is in the USAID global
development lab so when the other things
that's happening government is these
innovation labs where entrepreneurs and
residents not only the presidential
innovation fellows who come from outside
government but entrepreneurs and
residents from inside can come and do we
call it the NSA team calls it
Kickstarter and then mythbuster so you
have a Kickstarter time and he can show
some new prototype and then test it out
and build it the global development lab
is one at USAID
that's prototyping extraordinary things
so it's not only digital government but
also just what are we doing about the
connectivity deserts in our country
where connectivity is missing like a
food desert in other countries and
really getting the techies involved in
the global UN level conversations we've
been working with Samantha power
ambassador power here so it's really
exciting to work on all that and it
really is the
beginning of digital government and
inclusion in a Wikipedia way of all of
the talent of the world into that game
from you know the way the API is not
rfp's nagging on that note we thank you
for all that you do to bring government
to the tech community and to bring the
tech community to government Thanks and
thank you all for being here tonight